imagine instead of white gray or black
rooftops you look out over a sea of
green that stretches to the horizon
that's really what our vision looks like
long-term we're up top acres and we grow
food on roofs we convert underutilized
spaces into vibrant productive farmland
and we use this farmland to try to drive
the conversation to create better cities
to turn them from concrete jungles into
living breathing ecosystems 80% of the
US population lives in cities right now
and we are shipping food 1,500 miles on
average from farm to table so instead of
miles driven we're trying to measure the
distance our produce travels in flights
of stairs it's a lot more than just
growing food on roofs it's also about
how can we create the city of the future
and to make it a reality now the end
goal is really just to create a better
city this year we're shooting to have
about 17% of the produce grown on the
roofs distributed to the buildings that
those farms are on top of and then the
other 30% will go to the farmers market
and then also some restaurants in the
neighborhood
[Music]
you
I wanted to start up top acres because I
wanted to combine the two things that I
really like which is farming and living
in the city and I think that all three
of us deep down really wanted to try to
make our city that we grew up in that we
love truly a better place we're going to
deliver to market cafe called little red
fox there's some of our oldest clients
and we we love them up top Akers is one
of the local vendors that we work with
having ultra fresh produce it's a lot
more exciting for the customers just to
be able to know that like this was grown
downtown and got delivered this morning
so we're here on harvest day and we're
about to harvest some of our all-star
lettuce mix and it's going to be
distributed to our CSA members down in
the lobby of the building later today
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
I'm gonna go cook everyone benefits when
we're installing these systems you're
reducing energy costs you're reducing
stormwater runoff you have access to
fresh food and it's it's a benefit for
the surrounding community because these
are unique natural spaces that don't
usually exist in cities but we're right
on top of a metro station one of the
biggest things that sticks with me is
whenever anyone comes up onto the roof
they always have the same sort of
reaction it's why isn't this being done
on every building when I hear that
that's that's really what drives me is
let's make this a reality on every new
building that we're putting up
[Music]